ever since the franco-prussian war in
1870 to 1871 the Germans recognized that
there were likely to face another worth
France that was a war that allowed
Germany to unify the humiliated France
they were able to capture some very
valuable territory from France in
particular Alsace and Lorraine which is
very mineral rich and so the Germans
were plotting to well what are we going
to do if we get into another war with
them at the same time once France and
Russia had this alliance Germany fully
recognized that they if there is a war
with France it's likely to not be just
with France it's likely to be a
two-front war on the western front it'll
be a war it'll be they'll be in conflict
with France and on the Eastern Front
they'll be in conflict with Russia and
so to deal with this eventualities this
is all the scheming that Germany did in
the decades going up to World War one
they came up with the Schlieffen Plan
and I'm sure I'm mispronouncing it's
life in sleep in sleep in sleep sleep in
or Schlieffen Plan named for Alfred von
Schlieffen he was chief of the German
empires general staff from 1891 to 1905
and it was based on how do you deal with
the two-front war and the general ideas
here were that Russia Russia had a large
and almost inexhaustible army but
because it was so large it would take a
long time for it to mobilize a long time
to mobilize and the Germans are actually
able to approximate it correctly because
this is how long it did take the
Russians to mobilize at the beginning of
World War World War one they estimated
that it would take them about six weeks
so the Schlieffen or sleepin plan called
for enough German troops on the Eastern
Front initially in order to keep the
Russians at bay but then the main
fighting force of the Germans while the
Russians are mobilizing is to go after
France and try to essentially knock
France out of commission so that they're
not facing a two-front war anymore and
then have those troops go back to fight
against the Russians and the way that
they wanted to do it is by rolling
through Belgium in kind of a wheel like
pattern like this and the reason why
they want to do this wheel like pattern
is that they correctly predicted that
the French were very eager to get this
territory right over here and
French actually had a plan they call it
plan 17 for going after Alsace and
Lorraine it was an offensive plan and
the view is if the French army is going
in that direction if the German army
rolls through Belgium and is able to get
them from the rear they could put the
French army out of commission so in
early August 1914 the Germans once they
declared war on France and on Russia the
Germans tried to put the Schlieffen plan
into action and they frankly almost
succeeded
so through April through August and
early September the Germans were able to
essentially roll through Belgium were
able to roll through Belgium and keep
the combined mainly French forces but
there was also some assistance from
British to keep them on their heels and
this happened all the way until early
September when they get near the Marne
or a little bit past the Marne River in
France and it was here that the for that
the 6th French army so and when we talk
about armies we're talking about huge
numbers of troops the the 6th French
army had over two hundred thousand
troops in it when we're talking about
the Battle of the Marne which I'm about
to talk to we're talking about a the
First Battle of the Marne we're talking
about bat a battle that involves two
million troops so these are these are
battles that are occurring on an epic
scale just each of these armies this
army or this one right or the even the
the German armies we're talking about
hundreds tens of tens to hundreds of
thousands of troops in general an army
characterized you're talking about over
50,000 60,000 troops so what happens as
you go to early September especially
September 5th 1914 the 6th French army
recognizer recognizes a mistake that the
first German army made by trying to roll
around like this they exposed their
right flank so right over here would be
the right flank of the German army and
just is a most mammals our flanks are
kind of our our weak spot at that area
between your ribs and your hips the same
thing is true for armies the front of
the army tends to be where
have the strongest forces and then you
have your supply routes going back so if
you can outflank an army and that's why
a lot of military strategy is designed
around you can hit an army in it's
weaker points so by September 5th
the first German army recognized this
but it was too late by September 6th
they were at in battle they were they
were essentially being confronted by the
6th French army and by essentially
turning to meet them by turning to meet
them they created an opening between
them and the 2nd German army and that
that opening was able the the French and
the British were able to take advantage
of that to essentially put the Germans
on their heels after a month of
advancing and so right over here you
have the various you have the various
you have the various French armies and
they were assisted by the British
Expeditionary the British Expeditionary
Force
and so from the Battle of the Marne
which was essentially most most
historians would say between September
6th or September 5th September 6 and
September 12 they were able to put the
Germans on the retreat the Germans
recruited past the end River and then
once you get into November and the end
of the year of 1914 in a sense the
Germans essentially entrenched
themselves and literally they were
literally building deep trenches in in
northern France and a little bit of
western belgium and what i have right
over here let me see if i can draw what
i have right over here what the
boundaries are eventually happened after
the the Germans suffered essentially
their first big defeat they had to have
to retreat and they had to literally
reach wrench and this is what the
borders would then be like and they were
and and these were literally trenches
getting dug here and these borders up
you know this first stage of the wars
was hugely dynamic you had armies moving
fairly rapidly over a period of weeks
and months but then once the Germans
retrenched you have roughly this
position being static for the next three
years and the famous trench warfare of
the Western Front that you might have
seen movies on and I want to emphasize
this was a big deal the First Battle of
the Marne sometimes it's called the
miracle of the Marne
if that if the
if the French with British help were not
able to push the Germans back they might
have accomplished a sleep implant and
actually maybe he would have won World
War one or at least been able to win the
Western Front fairly quickly and then
been able to deal with the Russians a
little bit better but because of the
miracle at the Marne which was hugely
bloody we're talking about 500,000
casualties on both sides we're talking a
hundred to two hundred thousand dead on
both sides but because of that that was
able to hold off the Germans but it got
the Western Front in this kind of ugly
three-year long trench warfare